die zuschauer verfolgen doch sehr genau
wie ihr eigener score ist warum ist
diese formel eigentlich so geheim weil
so richtig lassen sie sich ja nicht
hinter die in die karten blicken wie
dieser score letztlich entsteht also der
score ist nicht geheim im grundsatz
sondern die datenschutzaufsicht die
schulen zuständig ist in hessen aber
auch alle anderen datenschutz aussichten
der länder oder auch des bundes wissen
womit wir arbeiten wie die formel
funktioniert
und dort ist also vollständige
transparenz
jetzt könnten sie fragen ja warum
erklären wir dass nicht jedermann
die frage ist wer sollte ein interesse
daran haben seinen score zu verbessern
dazu sollte man ja dann das wissen um
die formel benötigen doch nur der der
sich besser darstellen möchte als er ist
und genau da besteht wiederum das risiko
dass jemand wo ich mein score
manipuliere
und das würde man ja nur nach oben tun
sinnvollerweise stelle ich mich ja
besser da einem dritten gegenüber und
dessen vertrauen als kreditgeber ich ja
eigentlich werbe ich stelle mich aber
besser da als ich bin was meine
leistungsfähigkeit in sachen
rückzahlungsfähigkeit kreditlast angehen
und das ist schlicht und ergreifend eine
manipulation zu meinen gunsten zum
schaden des anderen und deswegen legen
wir die score formel nicht offen so dass
eben keiner sich mal sich der
möglichkeiten gibt dann doch mal den
manipulationsversuch zu wagen
das hat schlicht und ergreifend was mit
dem schutz der allgemeinheit zu tun und
mit dem schutz derjenigen die kredite
vergeben